[Musique]
et
bonjour à tous
aujourd'hui on est sur un gouffre dans
le xviiie à paris voilà au lancement du
view deux pros de wiko là derrière moi
j'ai une vie complètement dingue sur
paris vous avez au point bas pourrait
elle vous avez pas mal de choses et là
vous allez voir on est sur le toit
terrasse il ya une vue de dingue il ya
plein de monde derrière moi j'en ai fait
un petit tour
voilà la soirée se passe à l'intérieur
il ya plein de belles personnalités
aujourd'hui on a même rencontré soprano
[Musique]
soit pas non pas qu'elle a choisi de ne
pas y aller plus haut qu'est ce qui t'a
motivé
les incident marque marseillaise j'ai
entendu une histoire commencée dès
juillet c'est ce genre de trucs sur
toile par rapport à ces mesures via
célébrer les gens qui montent
je suis derrière l idée de d'un
smartphone connecté est vachement
collègues ont sauf que les affections
pas mal de choses oui ça c'est sûr dit
pas vraiment mais oui sommes pas parce
que
en fait il s'est de nouveau langage des
tirs et peut-être malheureusement et
heureusement parce que ça permet
justement de pouvoir communiquer avec
les gens ton univers
tes délires des désirs des dépouilles et
ça permet aussi de refaire un peu de
concerts montré des belles images
prendre des nouvelles malheureusement la
famille la chance d'avoir un ambassadeur
de marque vraiment le jeu unique est là
chaque fois sur tous vos événements et
c'est vraiment plaisir de la voir c'est
quoi l'idée d'être à chercher ce que je
lui posais la question et à leurs jolies
pourquoi travailler plus collant mettant
lui poser la question pourquoi aller
chercher soprano elle dit quoi cosider
du truc alors 10 18 rue qu'il ya il ya
différentes raisons tout d'abord soprano
les marseillais ont des d'entreprise
marseillaise on a quelque part d adn est
en tout cas des valeurs qui sont
vraiment comme une soprano c'est
quelqu'un qui sait d'où il vient
il n'oublie pas d'où il vient et c'est
quelqu'un qui a beaucoup de valeur
c'est quelqu'un qui est très proche de
son public très proche de ses caisses
que par consommateur et je pense que
c'est des valeurs qu'on partage avec
soprano et puis il faut être clair
soprano dans le public qui est quand
même assez assez jeune à ses millenium
et c'est exactement la cible
consommateurs de ricoh donc il y avait
beaucoup de beaucoup de synergies à
avoir effectivement un partenaire de
marque comme ceux très justement janvier
cette journée de fête pour effectivement
parler du vieux de croo on en a déjà
parlé à barcelone au mwc là on va aller
un peu plus loin que vous allez voir ce
qu'on peut faire avec ce produit on va
le tester
plus profondément 10 quelques jours mais
l'a pour l'instant l'heure est à la fête
et on va se balader un petit peu pour
voir un peu ce qui se passe sur sept et
vote qui est franchement une langue
d'ailleurs on peut des goûteurs il ya un
cas pour moi merci bombe a sauté
[Musique]
en gros le gros ballon avec jb je sais
j'y vais il est très connu jb alors j b
ouais c'est cool de se rencontrer ici
qu'est ce que tu en penses du coup
tricoter venu un peu voir comment je
l'avais déjà vu à barcelone
nbc on s'est croisé là bas c'est
rencontrer la part le 26 février
c'est cette je l'avais regardé
d'ailleurs fait de pitch de vidéos ouais
il est franchement cool moi je change de
design habituel qu'on a chez ricoh
une fois donne envie de tester donne
envie qu il a jadis un peu la gamme il
ya un côté qui vient le sexy ouais les
gens disent qu'ils en ont besoin
parce que vu toute la concurrence qui
arrive
ouais ça sert mal oui cauet raison en
février de sortir un téléphone qui sort
du lot ouais et qui qui est sexy
beaucoup parce que
il ya beaucoup contente et c'est bien
d'avoir des téléphones aujourd'hui
qu'ils sortent un peu du lot comme ça
envoie du bois du bois voilà c'est vrai
comment ça se passe pour toi très bien
tu as bien qu'on a encore réservé un peu
pour tout à leur maison un petit
champagne à weight watchers 6 go c'est
magnifique mais on va durer car les
marseillais le rideau ou en tout cas
j'ai la boite on va bientôt le tester
donc rester connecté abonné ou vous
allez voir on va faire des tests
complets on va le secouer tous les côtés
ça va être à nous être accord les gars
vous n'êtes pas tomber alors donc là
vous filmer une fille mais quoi légal
parce que là on est chez ricoh quand
même donc on s'est dit ça n'a rien à
voir avec mes copains à temps venteux
voilée quoi on a dû verser du co ceo de
gorm public ok qu'est ce qu'on peut
souhaiter aux rico beaucoup tentent
beaucoup de monde c'est la base quand
même de consolider sa place de numéro
deux sur le marché français et de
développer nos parts de marché au niveau
européen on est aujourd'hui la quatrième
marque la plus vendue en europe
il ya beaucoup de marchés qui s'ouvrent
à nous et sur lesquels on n'est pas
encore présent et donc l'idée c'est
vraiment de de consolider nos positions
sur des marchés sur lesquels on est de
développer nos parts de marché
au niveau global
[Musique]
il ya des choses que vous inspire le
parcours dessiné d'accord chez nous tout
arrêter mais là ce soir déjà on parle
effectivement de celui qu plus de pros
mais le plus important ce soir fait
quand même la fête est exact parce que
là tu parles
par exemple il faut parler de ce
smartphone c'est très important de
pouvoir le tester on adore les normes en
panne non mais non mais non non vous
parle à mes dents allez je sais pas
combien de temps va rester mais juste
après des lags moi je suis sur le
dancefloor qu'est ce qui t'inspire comme
ça juste de rapidement fait étrangement
c'est le le le renouveau un petit peu la
gastro de wilko c'est vraiment l'aspect
esthétique qui changent déjà avant toute
chose avant même de parler de
performance de stabilisation de ce genre
de choses tant que vivent ou y
cohabitent qu'aux jeunes vicois le roi
de la poigne de fer
je trouve que oui quoi vraiment se dire
bon allez assez facile on voit un petit
peu de bois rond grèce m entourent
niveau izod d'un point de vue esthétique
et c'est d'avoir quelque chose qui d'un
qui qui qui qui sexy voilà qui qui est
qu'un beau smartphone que tu as envie de
prendre de montrer plus t'as pas
longtemps je croyais que l'avion des
autres produits parce qu'il était quand
même bien on va pas se mentir
mais c'est vrai que c'est qu'avec ce ce
view de proust ou qui vont encore plus
loin il sait c'est un téléphone tu
prends tout passe à table il fait et
maintenant c'est qu'il est papa d'un
clairement pour moi suite à cécile c'est
vraiment une belle vitrine pour lui qu
on attend plein de nouvelles choses qui
vont arriver qu'ils vont continuer
d'arriver ou le septembre on verra ça il
fera très prochainement bon merci
beaucoup mais je tenterai bref tout
allait bien vous savez ça c'est beau
c'est l'amitié bon on continue
[Musique]
gallotta
màj
mais n'impose le mot merci merci de me
regarder cette vidéo allez mercian c'est
bientôt soyez samuel theis qu'avec très
bientôt la bulle
[Musique]